[Música]
é nisso que eu acredito
eu acredito que a gente põe no mundo
muda o mundo e não tem nada mais
poderoso do que dizer eu te amo uma
pessoa que você gosta
eu acho que é revolucionário falar eu te
amo porque primeiro não é muito comum os
nossos pais nossos avós
era um craque sem dizer a mano levanta
que homem não chora né não tá doendo é
isso aí vamos pra lá vão criar meu filho
pra ser forte porque aí fora tem um
mundo cruel e aí uma profecia que se
auto com pri né porque a gente cria um
monte de criança para ser cruel
essas crianças crescem ficam cruéis bom
para o mercado de trabalho competitivo
de forma cruel e aí o mundo realmente é
cruel e como é que a gente quebra isso
treinando crianças para ser gentil por
que ser gentil no mundo cruel não é
sinal de fraqueza
é sinal de coragem quebrar esse ciclo de
crueldade de dureza é sinal de coragem
se mostrava vulnerável é sinal de
coragem num mundo em que você não pode
demonstrar fraqueza ou vulnerabilidade
no mundo que homens são treinados para
serem fortes cruéis machos e aí lá na
frente a gente morre mais cedo previu
isso os homens trabalham criam os
malucos não falam sobre os seus
sentimentos e morrem antes deixando todo
o dinheiro as mulheres mulher com viajar
com a cvc pra nordeste com o nosso
dinheiro entendeu a gente guarda os
nossos sentimentos não fala eu te amo se
arrepende de não ter visto nossos filhos
crescerem porque a gente estava só no
escritório têm mais depressão vai - no
psicólogo é a maioria do sistema penal é
mais violento morre mais de forma
violenta
será que a gente não tá fazendo alguma
coisa errada e da onde que vença
crueldade essa dureza todas as nossas
referências anteriores realmente
antigamente mundo
tinha escassez guerra era um mundo
difícil eles não tinham 4g nem a cut era
difícil o mundo deles
eu trouxe aqui um enxerto de uma revista
que dava dicas para pais
o cuidado e alimentação de crianças 1935
1935 essa revista dá a seguinte dica
para pais nunca abrace o beijo seu filho
nunca deixa ele sentar no seu colo
se você precisar beijo na testa na hora
de dizer boa noite
aperte a mão dele pela manhã
faça um carinho na sua cabeça
se ele fizer algo realmente
extraordinário uma geração distante uma
geração treinada acreditar que formar
crianças cruéis era melhor para elas
porque o mundo é cruel
só que tem um coração bom e gentil é
sinal de coragem e se monta
quando você dizer eu te amo primeiro
quando você se mostra vulnerável você
acredita
de forma otimista que o mundo talvez não
seja assim tão cruel em algum momento a
nossa geração percebeu isso não
funcionou esse distanciamento com os
nossos pais
vou dar o meu filho afeto carinho amor e
limites também mas com afeto e gentileza
porque a gente acredita que isso é criar
crianças mais completas não é eu me
lembro quando falei eu te amo eu fui o
primeiro a falar na minha relação com a
minha esposa ana diz eu te amo e eu fico
super impactado o da tela azul não
conseguiu eu não sei o que dizer agora
nunca ninguém me disse isso o pai dela
não falava para ela a gente só dá o que
a gente recebeu um dia não é como eu
falei eu te amo pra ela ficou travada
mesmo de falar na frente dos meus amigos
no telefone com ela e beijo eu te amo os
meus amigos tinham um homem falando eu
te amo
demorou para alguns amigos meus
entenderem que quando você fala eu te
amo você não é menos um homem
e quando você expresse seus sentimentos
você não é menos homem você é mais homem
velho quando você respeitar sua esposa
quando você decide ser pai cuidar dos
seus filhos se não é menos homem você é
mais homem o amor nos uniu e ano ea
gente teve duas eles a gente cria as
nossas filhas com amor e carinho e como
eu te amo é a coisa mais linda do mundo
a receber esse amor de volta porque
quando eu estou dizendo eu te amo as
minhas filhas eu também sinto que estou
ouvindo eu te amo aquele eu te amo que
faltou na minha criação eu sinto que a
gente segura
atualmente eu sinto que o amor criando a
gente mas elo de ligação de vez em
quando eu to de escrever no meu quarto
minha filha gritou pai o que foi eu te
amo e é melhor que eu disse eu vi eu te
amo um contrato assinado e quantas vezes
nas gerações anteriores esse contrato
ficou em cima da mesa ea gente pensando
será que meu pai me ama vontade o
contrato será que ele vai assinar e ele
tem sendo é óbvio que eu te amo mas não
assinou o contrato ea gente cresceu uma
geração perguntando pelo terapeuta meu
pai amava meu pai amava eo terapeuta vai
dizer claro que pode te amava ele só não
conseguia dizer eles vão conseguir
assinar o contrato
uma vez a minha filha a gente estava
conversando com uma amiga e ela disse
você se acha bonita e era amigo do noivo
não e os seus filhos de chão bonita ela
disse não acho que não
e é a minha filha disse assim mas você
diz eu te amo com seus filhos porque
isso faz toda a diferença para criar
conexão a minha filha pequenininha falou
isso a gente se olhou disse burrel
reencarnação do front
e ela em determinado momento disse eu te
amo para o pai de ana a minha esposa
aquele pai que nunca tinha dito eu te
amo pra filha ouviu pela primeira vez da
neta
vou eu te amo e ele começou a chorar
porque ele nunca tinha ouvido aquilo que
a gente só dá o que a gente recebe
ele começou a chorar e tentar dizer eu
te amo para os filhos e
constrangedoramente não conseguiu e
morreu sem dizer eu tinha muitos felizes
porque é difícil porque eu te amo
constrange porque a gente não está
acostumado com isso porque precisa de
coragem para dizer eu te amo eu comecei
a falar sobre isso
e escrevi sobre isso e coloquei na rua
porque coisas lindas acontecem quando a
gente tenha a coragem de colocar os
nossos sentimentos na rua e foi
surpreendente como as pessoas começaram
a me inscrever
quando você fala sobre o que você está
sentindo quando você vulnerável as
pessoas começam a se mostrar vulneráveis
também em meu
hoje em dia as pessoas me param no
aeroporto veio aquele seu vídeo falando
sobre o poder do thiamo mudou minha vida
mandei pela tap meu pai meu pai falou
pela primeira vez eu te amo pra mim e
agora já está relembrando o quanto
aquilo fez falta na nossa relação e pais
dizendo que se reconectaram com filhos e
filhas dizendo que se reconectaram com o
pai e filha dizendo agora entendi tudo e
agora estou valorizando é exatamente que
vale a pena na vida de todas as pessoas
que me mandaram cartinhas a que eu mais
gostei foi essa aqui uma mamãe escreveu
o seguinte sábado passado fui visitar a
minha mãe numa clínica e ela tem
alzheimer ea comunicação é praticamente
inexistente uma frustração só pra nós
duas
pois neste dia inspirado pelo seu texto
o poder do time eu olhei bem nos olhos
dela e disse mãe eu te amo e ela me
puxou pra perto apertou a minha mão e
disse em alto e bom som
minha filha eu também te amo e me beijou
imagine cup angeles a emoção pra nós e
pra quem presenciou esse momento de amor
obrigado já valeu a pena de conhecer
toda vez que eu falei de coisas muito
caras e muito íntimas e coloquei isso na
internet
eu senti vontade de levantar depois eu
dizia raphael rabello tiros
isso é um pouco demais eu vou deletar
mas eventualmente o que a gente coloca
no mundo toca as pessoas e transforma
vidas dessas pessoas mais felizes e
começa a criar uma nova geração uma
geração melhor que a nossa
uma geração mais gentil que a nossa uma
geração sem tanto problema para resolver
no terapeuta uma geração que diz mais eu
te amo e que acredita no amor
o mundo é cheio de pessoas boas
se você não encontra elas seja uma muito
obrigado
[Música]